how's it going rest thanks for stopping
by my spread apart
let's continue the story somewhere at
Lauren's apartment we have a lot of
clues to investigate which I know you
both like it's fun it's children I know
[ __ ] Sherlock
is that the same knife you saw in the
mirror yes I don't know why it's over
here like his Vance I just don't
understand why would someone want to
kill him maybe it was suicide maybe he
found out that faith was dead and he
killed himself but that's his what
there's a bullet hole there that's a bit
suspicious maybe he missed he's like oh
I'll bullet pass through the chair yeah
angle work should be shot himself I'll
snap east new mate see I'm a genius I
might not have an idiot
why is that more blood app strange hard
edge to this pool like something was
here and got moved
whatever I'll say about this situation
well that was useful son of a what what
do we got another note my dear
can we read it please it's not to look
bad a little my oh my dearest faith I
never meant to hurt you
and I cannot endure knowing that I have
this was for the best I'll see you again
love your devoted Laurence so he did
count self so why did he do exactly we
do together now about all we can hope
for at this point
it's like at this picture maybe it's a
staged suicide like I'm sorry faces
before all this well no [ __ ] huh let's
look at the bullet hole see if we can
get the bullet out
alright let's examine Lawrence and then
we ready
what is it how long is using it smell
wasn't fired recently maybe a week ago
or is it maybe but it's really hard to
kill yourself if you're like a fable
right you can tell that just by smelling
fingerprints they'll be on the grip and
the trigger
what are they prescription sleeping
pills all right Sal Meredith okay that
doesn't really help
well I'm sorry just want to make sure we
investigate everything looks like it
okay um I think we're done here but this
needs to be more over here dusty no
one's read these in a while what about
the closet
Oh job blada stay here Oh scared Mike no
way god damn [ __ ] my doc what is wrong
with me hey stop huh how's that fast so
fast that's the guy from the flat oh
it's on like Donkey Kong dang you come
over here
hell yeah [ __ ] dog shows [ __ ]
like a dog joke Oh Shay are you okay
there sorry
actually I don't give a [ __ ] it's got to
get over
which way which way this way where the
[ __ ] did he go closet oh [ __ ]
window you almost gave you the slip
house that fat guy so awesome at parkour
don't do Oh God
god dammit oh [ __ ] huh
I think he's upstairs but I'm not sure
come on maybe holy [ __ ] and that's how
it's done ladies in bed
damn he's up baby we're on the same side
here and that's how you're running son
of a [ __ ]
make me run after you why did you run
what why did you run [ __ ] man because he
chased after me the [ __ ] was I supposed
to do
no you started running man's dead I know
how it looks but I had nothing to do
with that man who did it then who did
look I was just asking him about the
girl that's all and I mentioned her
being dead he freaked out I think if
someone had told him how was I supposed
to know [ __ ] [ __ ] shot himself right
in front of me I couldn't stop him man
what are you doing the closet then
you're looking for the woodsman and he
had any time the writer no he is my guy
says he's holed up at the trip-trap we
can go over there right now
the both of us it's nice my employers
looking to ask him a few questions too
marine boy were you doing back there
checking out the guy was married to the
girl saved a good place to start
tracking down leads what kind of leads
oh I can't tell you that it's
confidential
sorry sure you understand nope can't say
that I do come on you're coming with me
this could have been easy but don't
worry it still is
come on dum-dum yeah it is
look it'd be much easier for you gonna
do I'm T he's dumb Oh Oh is those two is
it those two from from that fed Alice
you almost looked peaceful
yeah except you're lying in a dirty
alley yep
with an open wound on the back of your
head where do you think our big go well
after the one guy hit you and the other
one finished kicking you
that explains the ribs then they jumped
into a car and drove off come on get up
yes we're out of options do you mention
the trip-trap then that's where we'll go
I'll call a cab [ __ ] man I knew I should
have hit him I know he was lying Sam see
it see every time I think I'm getting a
handle on what's going on
things just get more complicated it
feels like we're always a step behind
the woodsman is the only lead we've got
and he was one of the last people to see
faith alive
getting some answers out of him we'll
start to clear things yeah it's about
time we visit any hope you're right Big
D be honest with me who do you think did
this
I know it's still early but what are you
resting just feel a step behind it
wasn't a husband I doubt it comfortable
feeling I don't know I really [ __ ]
don't know lubing we haven't talked to
him yet but tell me how do you best
think the woods Mac it doesn't matter
this point I feel like Bluebeard has
something to do with this I had the same
suspicion I don't know how her well I
just yet but if you're asking this is
his MO there's still a lot of questions
we find the woodsman figure out what he
knows and go from there makes sense
that's probably the best approach I felt
like they what they just want you to
think it's the woods man but it would be
too obvious that it's the Wits men in my
opinion and I don't know who else to
pick and we don't know anything about
Bluebeard so good job girl your doors
are really awkward go ahead go ahead
I didn't mean to cut you off no it's I
shipped them so much biscuit nothing I
just not a creep seeing all this today
they're fables that are struggling worse
than I'd imagined we pay so much
attention to the residents of the
wetlands you forget there's a whole
community out there to serve to have to
turn to prostitution I I wish there was
more we could do this isn't how I
thought it would be
but crane runs things his own way you're
doing your best gosh it's all anyone can
do obviously you don't know what I do
all day right now I'm the gatekeeper
making sure none of these
disenfranchised folks are as he puts it
wasting his time you'll fix it
I don't know
it's just a broken system the fables who
walk in through the back door like
Bluebeard we have all the time in the
world for them you try and come in
through the front door through the
proper channels asking for anything
eating help well I turned you away
it's a [ __ ] up system
now things are worse off than they've
ever been
that's not true right we've had it worse
maybe this is it for me I thought public
service was pure we'll figure it out
he'll figure it out you're better than I
am with this political stuff well that's
not saying much I trust you to make the
right decision I hope you're right
okay
we arrived at the woodsman I get a
feeling ya know whoa is that the pimp
yeah maybe I should accept I handle all
of them three apples
Begbie oh god damn what's up girl
I just be careful please
oh hi well babe
always always
you got to say with vanas approach the
ladies love it they do
I'm gonna go and do it as bad as Bing
how did the cab know to drive anyway Oh
make any sense
and now we are at the trip track bar in
the Bronx that fan is fun at it up girl
we have yet to see some big bad wolf in
the action but I wouldn't be surprised
by absent who she's supposed to be we
see him before what do you want sheriff
I'm looking for the woodsman well he's
not here so I guess you can go now well
then you gonna tell me where you're not
even gonna ask where he is now okay
I just want to know the last time he was
here that's all who I'm being nice so
try again
he hasn't been here for a few weeks
No maybe I don't know but yeah he hasn't
been here in a while if he's been here
at all which uh I don't know
yeah you can decide by us I'll tell you
what to do you're your own woman well
this is me talking Big B [ __ ] off you
think you're clever huh
well then I'll have a chat with your
well hats on man have you seen the
woodsman around I don't know who that is
big guy beard flannel kind of a [ __ ] bag
hard to miss you sure you don't know
what a drink help you remember I buy you
a drink how about you keep your drink
good piss off
all right I guess we got to look for
clues then why would you keep out of the
mystery for you they're pickled eggs oh
I know what they are I'm just trying to
figure out why anyone would eat this hey
eggs they're disgusting they smell like
diarrhea I don't understand how you can
eat eggs I hope I'm not the only one I
really do
you got any change for this thing no I
like the solo in the background well
maybe we can find some change
free beer tomorrow hahaha a lot of
stools in this place only one next year
there's only one right next to you
you're gonna order something
are you just here to bother my customers
no like oh you know what I mean I guess
I'll have it
give me a Midas Gold you want a lime no
no well I don't got any anyway I think
that's funny
yep I think it's [ __ ] hilarious
your face is [ __ ] hilarious
this is serious Holly harboring a
fugitive is gonna get you in as much
trouble as he sin you could lose
everything
is that gonna be him is that gonna be
him
I don't like where this is going
Ollie Oh 1,000 you took a [ __ ] just like
you art 100 how's this brain still
working after having a [ __ ] axe
inside of it shaved your beer for you
I should have pressed Malory to clear it
but I said no he'll be back now here you
are you and me been gone up for hundreds
of years
I'm through fighting
well that makes two of us l woody that
makes two of us
your luck I decided to switch seats what
the [ __ ] do you want now [ __ ] with me
last fella put his hand on me ended up
with an axe in his head last fella I put
my hand on ended up in the ground okay
grant
it's funny just a minute ago no one
seemed to know who you were yeah well
everyone knows you big bad wolf no I'm
the bad guy in your sheriff kind of [ __ ]
yeah you play the hand you're dealt
now there's not much to explain it's no
big secret I needed money and walked
past her place for weeks she didn't look
like it she had money that was sure of
it well she didn't have money she
wouldn't put up any kind of flight
I was gonna rob her and the night I
finally get up the nerve to do it there
you are
[ __ ] things up for me you were just
in the wrong place at the wrong time
so was it robbery planning on robbing
her love her and her grandma grandma
wait what are you talking about oh she
is Little Red Riding Hood her
grandmother I was there to rob him
nobody did well he wasn't I showed up
you were already there lying in the bed
I only saved her cuz I thought you might
give me a reward but she didn't give me
[ __ ] except a bunch of people thinking
I'm something I eat when I played along
as long as I could only thing I managed
to get from it was a free drink every
now and again I'll her Nellie sorry I
already know this story woody you should
you were there not talking about Red
Riding Hood I'm here about faith she was
murdered
what faith was that girl you were beaten
on this morning no no no no no I I was
here
what I'm not good when a girl you were
just smacking around shows up dead hours
later she's dead big you listen I I'm a
piece of [ __ ] okay I know that I hit
that girl I did I I shouldn't know but I
didn't kill her don't even think leave
me right I believed him die they're
gonna string me up Big B is this so I
don't it looks [ __ ] bad it looks
really bad but I didn't do it he was
here that's the [ __ ] truth sheriff
you see baby please you can't they'll
throw me down the witchin well that's
what they'll do and I didn't do it you
know that the witching mill the funny
thing
hey stop this isn't what I want oh shut
the [ __ ] up woody
[ __ ] ain't just about you it's about
this [ __ ] lapdog when it comes
sniffing around this part of town when
the rich [ __ ] and the woodlands need a
shakedown ain't that right Big B your
lap dog dog
really I want that free beer today
missin no one gives two shits about her
paperwork waiting rooms and that [ __ ]
snow-white looking right past me then
ushering me out the [ __ ] door
[ __ ] you that all you got seem to be
enough yeah that be so sure oh it's on
oh whoa whoa who the hell is he pull the
hell in here
who the [ __ ] are you god damn you're
ugly what much better tell her easy walk
out of here we had the chance come on
you're scaring look don't worry about me
oh [ __ ]
the guys are playing around huh god damn
I think the wolf has to come out or
unless snow is gonna save us my shoulder
did you get up and dance nice eye bro
hey miss me
missed me [ __ ] what about it oh [ __ ]
Oh snappy slow buy some new shoes you
ugly an AA
how much damage gonna dad hike ah
No
the woods would smell what he's gonna do
something aren't you woody come on woody
that a yes oh oh okay yeah nice beer run
it's a good superpower grow a beard in
two seconds
I want that superpower [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] up that was easy dad oh you want
some of this
oh oh I'm the lap dog oh here you
[ __ ] monster I'm sorry it's is that
he calling me a dog they're the [ __ ]
monsters like I want to leave me I
whiskey double
yeah I'm sorry to not like the character
now even though it's my choice but that
was kind of a crazy move this tear off
his arm how can I say no to that
so alcohol makes him sane huh I just pay
for the drink don't even think about it
is this a type of treatment I can expect
if I let you two take me in he started
it he started
all right I got a hundred bucks for the
first bloke that can tell me something
about a girl named oh you're in trouble
[ __ ] you're in big trouble
no I don't want to kill woody I have no
quarry with you woody
oh I'm definitely picking him oh [ __ ]
des sessions uh uh uh you bros decide
next episode
ah ah dude dad look at me like that
do you see how so my god I know I look
good but I mean hi not go [ __ ] [ __ ]